hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the third leg of the
fide grand prix uh it's the semi-finals
shaktir madara versus hikaru nakamura
the first uh classical games or rather
the two only classical games they played
ended in a draw and now they go into
rapid tie breaks and the first rapid
type break game was won by hikaru where
he had the white pieces nama madara has
the white pieces
and he will of course try to win and
force further tie breaks um now it's
always very interesting when you have
tie breaks and then one player wins the
first game the other one tends to get
very very wild
as uh well as is the case here so
without further ado let's check it out
uh shock there with the white pieces
opens with c4 uh sorry about that
uh we have knight to f6 by hikaru uh
countering the uh english defense this
way uh we have g3 e5 ending now bishop
to g2 grabbing hold of this beautiful
diagonal we have c6 now countering the
light square bishop preparing to further
um developing the center with a move
like d5 so d4 we have e captures on the
for queen captures and now as uh you can
develop the knight to c6 there's a pawn
there we're going to play knight to a6
and that way we guard the c5 square so
we can develop our bishop to this very
active square so knight to c3 we have
bishop to c5 and now queen back to d1
we have castles by hikaru and the
shakira goes knight to f3 he also
prepares the castle d6 now and here that
we have castles we have bishop to e6 and
now the c4 pawn is attacked we play b3
so if you look at this position now one
should or rather would prefer white the
bishop is coming here the two bishops
will be nicely fianceed all the pieces
are very harmoniously developed whereas
the cars pieces are
still uh not all there in the game the
knight still has to go back to c6 a c7
then find its way back into the game and
we still have to develop the rook so
it's a perfectly fine position but um a
white should be preferred here and as uh
mama made up allowed it now hikar will
execute the d5 uh and there is one game
where knights to g5 was played just
going after the light square bishop also
opening up this bishop but here we have
c captures on the e5 and it is now as of
movie 11 that we have a completely new
game so hikaru trades with knight
captures on the e5 all the traits favor
hikaru he won the first game now a draw
gets him to the finals uh so knight to
e4 uh declining the trade and the bishop
back to e7 we of course want to keep the
bishop pair bishop to b2 grabbing hold
of this diagonal and now knight to f6
hikaru offers more trades we have knight
eat the g5 and now as the queen trade is
on the table he carries us straight so
queen captures on the one rook a
captures on d1 and now what do you play
here well uh the bishop on e6 is
attacked and uh hikaru doesn't wanna
lose the bishop pair for nothing so he
brings the bishop back to c8 now this is
a very brave move uh first of all you
are once again disconnecting your rook
so you are gonna have to develop your
light square bishop again and you still
have to bring this knight into the game
so here mamidaro is just up in
development so knight the d4 opening up
the light square bishop as well and now
rook the e8 uh here mamadirov sets a
little trap and maybe hikaru should play
something like h6 first to get rid of
the knight and then bring the rook into
the game uh but he plays it right away
and now mamidarov gets the uh pull off
his plan and that is knight captures on
c6 uh grabbing two pawns and then of
course once the bishop captures you will
be attacking both rooks here so b
captures on c6 bishop captures on c6 and
now bishop to f5 you have to give up one
of the rooks but now uh maderov doesn't
grab the rook right away first e4
attacking the bishop bishop back to g6
and now uh this pawn will be a liability
once the light square bishop is uh is
traded so you're going to have to do
something about it and the momentum
plays f3
e5 would have been much much uh much
better uh but it's a rapid game you
don't have all the time in the world so
you have to settle for four things here
and then uh so f3 defending on e4 and
now knight to g4 this beautiful move is
what gives hikaru the uh well just the
opportunity to equalize on the spot now
he's threatening to pick up the knight
here and uh also this knight the e3
going for the uh
for for the rook fork here will be more
than enough for him so bishop back to c1
and now not only defending the knight
but guarding the e3 square from the
knight and bishop to c5 with check we
have king to g2 and now knight to e3
check hikaru now wins the bishop pair
bishop captures we have bishop captures
and now
knight to h3 the knight and g5 is still
hanging so knight h3 and now knight to
b4 getting the knight into the game and
forcing the bishop to finally capture
one of the rooks so bishop captures an
e8 rook captures an e8 and now knight to
f4 and if you look at this position uh
mamadorf's position is uh well it's it's
uh very nice uh he he has uh
a rook for two bishops which doesn't
seem like much but he is up to pawns and
what do you do here uh the problem is if
you if you capture the knight for
example captures captures then uh the
light square bishop is no longer really
in the game and the white will be just
much better here so he car grabs the a2
pawn he says all right you were up two
pawns now you are up one pawn but now
comes knight to d5 attacking the bishop
here so bishop back to c5 and now rook
to a1 attacking the knight and then of
course the a7 pawn will fall as well so
knight to b4 we have knight captures on
b4 bishop captures and rook captures on
a7 and now you have this position where
uh maduro is still up two pawns and he
also has a past b pawn so that's very
dangerous the problem is hikaru
still has the bishop pair and he has the
opportunity to open up the game and with
the king wide open the bishop pair will
be a deadly duo so he starts with f5 now
there's no way to uh to keep the
position closed uh you have to play
something so here we have captures and
now rook to e to check first we have
king to h1
or you could block with rook to f2 but
after rook to f2 we just capture
captures captures and bishop to c5 check
picks up the other rook uh so not
something you wanted and it would still
be uh pretty pretty interesting for
example king moves we're going to
capture on a7 pawn captures bishop here
h captures uh you have all of these
spawns against the bishop with perfect
play it might be a draw
but
you you will have to work for it uh so
instead after rook to e2 chuck king the
h1 is played but now hikaru gets even
more counter play queen bishop captures
on f5
rook the b7 attacking the bishop here
and now not moving the bishop but rather
bishop to h3 offering that bishop for a
rook on f1
so what do you play here uh well mahmoud
doesn't want to see he carves bishop on
c5 because if this bishop comes to c5
then bishop
g2 will just be checkmate so he blocks
this he plays rook to c1 prevents bishop
to c5 but the position is still
completely lost for mahmoud so feel free
to pause the video and find the absolute
quickest way to win for hikaru it's
actually a forced checkmate in seven
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
move uh mahmoud tried to prevent is the
exact move that actually wins the game
for kikaru the quickest and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course bishop the c5 this is what
he carver played and he was in this
position on move 34 that mamidarov
shahriar resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh the
problem is we are guarding the g1 square
and bishop to g2 will be checkmate on
the next move and of course you cannot
just capture the bishop because then
rook to e1 is checkmate the king has no
squares
so the only thing you could do after
bishop to c5 is go for some rogue b8
check maybe king f7 rook to b7 check and
then after king to e6 you run out of
checks uh or you could start giving up
pieces you're going to have to play rook
to g1 but now we just play bishop the g2
check
and we even give up some material for
checkmate we'll capture some g2 rook the
e1 check now the only move is rook to g1
for white and of course rook captures on
g1 will be checkmate so of course
mahmodarov saw all of this after bishop
the siva f5 was played and he was in
this position that he resigned in the
game
so brilliant games by both of them
especially in the in the classical time
format but in the rapid section hikaru
once again shows uh that he is indeed
the speed demon by winning both of the
rapid games and now he will face uh
wesley so in the finals of the third leg
of the video grand prix and we'll see uh
how that will work out we're gonna cover
uh some of the games or maybe even all
of the games it is the finals uh we'll
see uh what the games will be like uh so
yeah very impressive uh stuff by hikaru
uh one of the one of the candidates of
the 2022 phoenix candidates tournament
very much looking forward to that and i
know you guys are as well and i know uh
we all know of course that magnus said
that he will only play alireza if
alireza wins the candidates tournament
but i could not imagine for example if
he car wins the candidates that magnus
would not play hikaru i think that would
be that would definitely be the most
viewed world chess championship match uh
ever played uh well
considering uh how many followers both
of them have
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it once again
congratulations if you found this bishop
the c5 idea really really a wonderful
stuff i would like to thank adam tomczyk
smokey doula open c smoky doula and
richard mckevin for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the grand
prix checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend